[Music]
for too
long tam what edgar's crying over broken
tyranny
it's okay hey it's okay because now
we have double tambourine
it's stronger than ever before oh
i'll i'll get some flex tape and then
it'll be like
new you know the world seems broken at
times
one day your tambourine breaks the next
day
people are rioting so i thought today
we just get a break from all that and we
look at some god damn
wholesome memes cause lo knows it's been
a tough couple months
for everybody maybe this will cheer us
up
i go to the same gas station every day
after work for beer and burritos
today when i asked for my burrito the
guy said
they're high i knew you'd be here so i
made a fresh batch
and that's the most thoughtful anyone's
done for me
in a while this is the top voted of
all time a man literally just heated up
burritos for another man
and that's enough to make a grown man
cry god damn it it's funny when
when generally nice acts happen to
strangers
and you're just reminded like what what
there's nice people there's nice acts in
this world what
i play a lot of rocket league and uh
usually it's people telling you
but then i play this one game and my
teammate just left right away and the
and the other two guys were like it's
all right we can just play one versus
one
and then they took turns to play against
me
and i'm like holy [ __ ] this is so
awesome gamers
hoping gamers restored and they lost
because they sucked obviously but still
found my clones selling nuts in istanbul
we couldn't communicate but the whole
market was
[Laughter]
oh that's funny i want to find a
doppelganger one day
no one looks like me oh wait i heard
about this guy called felix shelby
he just kind of resembled me a little
bit yeah he does look a little bit like
me
i'm not gonna lie but i don't know who
the [ __ ] he is it looks pretty cringy to
be honest
took my six-year-old to a classmate's
birthday party today
he was the only other kid there his
parents thanked me for bringing him and
said he was the only one their son
wanted to invite because my son's the
only one
in school who's nice to him teach your
kids not to be
[ __ ] be nice to kids in school
everyone's afraid to be nice because
they think it's not cool but it's cool
to be nice god damn it
i'm not gonna be nice it's lame but i'm
telling you for other people who wants
to be that
uh my grandpa who knows nothing about
video games but loves me very much and
wants to relate to me
are you winning son oh it is i didn't
read it
i swear i didn't read it that's funny
are you winning yes yes i'm playing
terraria
yes i'm winning dad i built not just one
meatball
but i had two meatballs and an ikea
tower in between in terraria
of course i'm winning grandad i'm a
gamer
subscribe and become a member guys check
out the live streams it's an epic time
you'll be winning instantly pp size 20
increase
ever since i was a little kid i always
wanted to get in a fire truck i'm
tempted to just walk my grown ass over
to a fire station and just asked
oh my god it works it's surprising how
much you can get away with if you
literally just ask that's amazing good
on the brooklyn
brookline fire department i don't know
if that's the case
if you ever find yourself cringing at
something you did in the past it means
you have grown as
a person no it means you were a failure
screw this
reddit what is your wish mortal
well i wish i could stop second guessing
myself really
you're going to wish for that hey it's
my wish so i get to be there
hey does that mean i still
keep thinking mom making food for her
children versus herself
oh oh
mom you make my heart crack this should
be the main banner for the subreddit
it's such a good photo boys that one
compliment they got years ago
yes uh i can remember like a handful of
compliments i got from strangers and
it's so imprinted in my memory it's so
true
we're weak every time someone made you a
sandwich
and every time you got a compliment from
a stranger that's it that's burning your
mind forever
i'll forget what i ate for breakfast but
those things will never go away
my 79 year old grandma has a meme framed
legend i bet you don't have a meme frame
huh
why does a 70 or grandma have better
meme game than you cringe
i don't have my memes frame because i
don't have walls okay floor only
only floor
[Laughter]
are you ben yes he's my best friend he
always comes to watch the match
it always always
[Laughter]
being called sir by a brit being called
sweetie by a southerner being called
sugar by an old black lady being called
champ by a dead being called comrade by
a drunk rush
it doesn't get more wholesome than that
you cannot get any stronger connection
with a stranger
than a comrade drunk russian i'll show
you mine
if you show me yours
no floor gang would not let this happen
minus 100 body fat subscribe
we're trying to beat coco melon leg
reveal if
at 110 million subs let's get it
when you have only one item in the line
at the grocery store and the person in
front of you lets you go ahead of you
of them that was very cash money of you
i feel like this is one of those things
that just
is so accepted that you should be that
if i have this
and no one likes me through i'm like
what the what's wrong with you what's
wrong with you
i have one item over here kindness only
goes so far
i have one item goddammit what's wrong
with you yeah you better let me go
sorry i'm ruining wholesomeness i
understand i'm the problem
my family leaving me out during presents
because i'm too old
my grandma a gift card that is so nice
grandma never forgets anyone i remember
my grandma got me legend of zelda on the
64.
and i was like oh my god how does my
grandma
have such good taste in games this game
is [ __ ] awesome
oh thank you grandma thank you even
though it was my mom that told you
still thank you oh my god i didn't know
this
let's celebrate naoko takeuchi
she was a struggling artist when she
created sailor moon i was at a low place
so i write about girls i wish for my
friends
i'm sorry for anything bad i said about
sailor moon it's an amazing anime
[Laughter]
haha goodbye 2019 now things will start
to get better
oh no no no no no 2020
will it hurt what no we're going to work
together for this to be a good year
but why were you drawing this strong i
go to the gym
floor again 100 muscle increase defeat
coca mello become member pp size
increased 20
thank you time traveler what year is it
me
it's 20 20. time traveler what month me
june why time traveler good the worst is
over
please please let it end the june please
okay
i'm not even wearing pants this has gone
on too long man
it's a goddamn too long man i'm not even
wearing pants
leg reveal my knees reveal
they're not even watched like reveal
at 110 million yes i know english thank
you
when you lower the brightness of your
meme for the redditors trying to sleep
it ain't much but it's honest work i
mean i'm not gonna lie this is more
comfortable
but at the same time why are people
treating light mode like it's
burning the rice out
ah my eyes
what a great meme template i've never
seen that my parents the way my parents
see me
me damn that [ __ ]
suit though i want it i want it dad's
showing other dads the ribs they grilled
over the weekend
check out these ribs leo oh hell yeah
i'm gonna do a little dance for those
ramps freaky
you two know you can come in right no
thank you we're waiting for
ah ah and you'll never leave me
edgar never leave me i love you
he'll he'll go right in when you revisit
a game which you played in your
childhood and there's no four 40
gigabyte update yet
god damn it i'm not even excited about
the next-gen
stuff because of all of this you're not
starting over you're starting with
experience i've always
thought of this like this i never mind
uh
starting over i mean of course it's
annoying but i always kept this in mind
are you winning son yep i'm having a
great dance thanks dad
thanks dad watch his boku no piku yeah
i'm having a great time dad
please leave us alone our busy dad
can't wait to have a kid so i can
ironically come in with a cigar and a
hat
and whatever the hell that is are you
winning son
when i was your age i had millions of
subscribers
you ain't nothing you ain't nothing you
even flew again
you disappointed you didn't boil it to
me i can't believe you share my jeans
my jeans it's 20 20 and people still
don't know who tony hawk is
okay we get it tony hawk no one knows
who you are
stop bragging about it i'm such a legend
but these kids don't even know who i
am but i'm such a legend uh seeing human
touch my ball
realizing my ball now has seized
basically doggy or a hedgehog
sorry after i assassinated you if it
looked like i was oh i seen this if it
looked like i was teabagging
i was trying to not get hit in the head
i'm so sorry
i feel like this is a copy pasta you can
use just to piss people off
i was totally not a lot of talk about
bob rush and mr rogers
but not enough credit goes to this
inspiration too many
that's uh that's the guy from star trek
isn't it
the glasses guy right that's him
george left forge jordy left forge
i swear he was looking at anime titties
the whole time i swear
if you're jumping on the avatar last
airbed
airbender bandwagon just because it's on
netflix and never even watched it as a
kid
let me just be straightforward welcome
aboard i hope you enjoyed it as much as
i did
and do surprise not gay keeper
oh pewdiepie can't talk about jojo then
a bunch of other people will talk about
jojo and then he ruined now i can't
watch it anymore
even though it's clearly already very
popular just found out that my husband
fills the dog's water dish not from the
tap but from the fridge water purify
feature
she did the same for me he said
i do this with maya i always make sure
she drinks it the same way i do because
i'm like well
i wouldn't want it that way she deserves
it
now you ain't there not you you don't
deserve it
again come here i'm sorry i'm sorry it
was a joke
it was a joke i love you i love you
edgar okay
you love me you want to hit the
tambourine for me bro
[Music]
hell yeah that's my boy that's my boy
right there
hell yeah hell yeah oh look how happy
you can't see him because i'm hiding my
legs that i don't have
when someone compliments your english
and it's your second language
whenever people do it to me i'm like no
shut up
your english so good yeah i lived here
seven years eight years okay
yeah it should be good god damn better
be good
and it isn't i know that it isn't i'm so
bad at getting compliments
when you pet a dog and the owner says
wow he never let strangers do that
not my dog edgar wants attention from
everyone
that's not a [ __ ] bee that's a humble
bee or whatever they're called in
english
see i don't go to english i don't do
good english
they don't sting you so why should you
be scared i'll murder an actual bee i
don't give a [ __ ]
i don't care about bees i don't care
about bees
this is supposed to be wholesome felix i
mean love each other and the world
better
if you put your trash in your pocket to
avoid littering you're going to happen
guess i'm going to heaven guys what's
the big deal
when you accidentally step on your
doggo's paw and treat him like a god for
the rest of that day
a valencia fan had his season ticket for
years
he ended up going blind in his 50s but
kept his season ticket because he wanted
to feel the atmosphere of the games
when he passed away two years ago the
club put a statue of him in his seat
so he could forever be at the games oh
i feel my heart
oh
oh that's funny parallel universe be
like
ceiling gang sailing no no
no me learning and using basic swedish
whenever i can
my swedish girlfriend who speaks perfect
english i feel like swedish is a lot
harder to learn though
and i don't understand why anyone would
learn that language everyone speaks
english in sweden anyways
hilarious i did not expect that
i was gonna joke yeah you guys know
swedish from watching my videos anyway
right
all right that was wholesome memes very
wholesome
very fun if you enjoyed this video hit
gently the like button thank you very
much
subscribe we're trying to kill coco mel
i'm just kidding and uh become members
support the channel i really appreciate
it
all goes to charity there's a ton of
perks check them out it's free right now
if you're in the uk
japan and some other countries you know
what since this is wholesome
bro fish yeah
children of nine parts
it's time to raise what was once
forgotten
what creatures fart spells and poop
troops awaits
poopty is coming to
nintendo switch
and remember it has a very big pp
pre-order promotion i mean